oh that's oh hey what's up kids this is
Dave fails I'm Kate quickly this is this
is like a Kate update episode I decided
that we just need kind of a recap of
what's going on in life I know I do I
know Jen does I know cuz you've been so
busy lately we've barely talked I know
and I so he thinks I'm avoiding her and
it couldn't be further from the truth
I've literally slept maybe a total of
six hours this week and I'm ready to
jump off yeah you've been crazy but
you're lucky this podcast is on the
first floor or you'd be talking me off
the ledge Jedidiah Jedidiah relationship
is so funny because you're the closest
thing I have to a boyfriend I know I'm
so screwed and we get we have a lover's
spat like real lovers do but the thing
is that my I'm definitely the dude
that's the problem I don't think you're
always the dude I think sometimes I'm
the dude yeah sometimes you are they do
go back and forth we take turns being
the dude really do ya
I didn't say who's here but obviously
it's my BFF Jen Sturgis I knew from the
voice with the dude voice it's great if
anyone has a dude voice here it's me did
I ever tell you that when I was a kid I
used to get made fun of for my voice all
the boys in my neighborhood called me
roids and I had a unibrow and no boobs
so like all my killing is what you're
saying oh my god I was the ugliest I was
the ugliest junior high kid I wish I had
photos one day I'm gonna bring in food I
think we should compare I was ugly all
the way through college really until I
was like I didn't really start to get
decently attractive until probably like
24 yeah no I I think for me yeah it was
right around the same time really I look
back at pictures well I mean I think you
were hot in college you were like the
FSU because people have really low
standards in college
no you were super hot in college I saw
photos but I didn't have eyebrows and so
now like do you ever look back at
pictures of yourself and be like what
was I thinking
oh my god actually the other day I
texted you and I said I'm thinking about
selling my wedding dress for those of
you don't know I was married at 19 in
Ohio and my wedding dress is like I got
it David's Bridal it looks like
something Belle would wear in Beauty and
the Beast
it's literally like the top is like a
corset was spaghetti straps and then the
bottom it's just this huge poufy tulle
oh my god it was like yeah because I was
so back then when I got married I was in
love and now you're like screw this yeah
I was still young enough to like have
the whole fantasy of like the perfect
princess wedding and that's what I
thought it was never talked about my
wedding on here this is actually this is
like a trip down memory lane it was do
you remember any of it
I remember all of the planning and
barely any of the wedding that's what I
always tell my friends like you're gonna
get engaged soon and I'm gonna tell you
that whatever you do cuz people put so
much pressure I hire someone else to
plan everything I'm not surprised me
yeah that's great then I get there I'm
like this sucks that's that's the thing
it's like you put so much there's so
much stress and planning it especially
if your family is involved because
everybody wants different things in your
port a million different ways I don't
give a [ __ ] what my family things sorry
right now
this election has torn my family apart
are you serious oh yeah why because my
parents are deeply southern and like
just they've they've really bought into
the whole fear mongering thing over
money because they both came from like
well my mom came from a little bit of
money but my dad was like dirt poor yeah
and so like any time you mentioned if
you told my dad he was gonna lose five
dollars he would have a heart attack
like he's all about like particularly
money because when you're poor like the
littlest bit of you know of money
matters to you so yeah I can't yeah my
parents think yes I returned two jug of
milk
milk doesn't taste right like you drink
half the gallon like yeah it's really
something's off can I get four do I need
a latte
that's no but I get it man that's that's
but yeah I do but I look like in
pictures of myself in college and I go
what was I thinking
on all fronts well when I look at my
wedding photos
I mean first of all my eyebrows my
eyebrows were so uneven like when I was
so thin my really didn't have any I look
like a make-a-wish kid well if you were
you could get your wedding for free at
least that would be a bonus yeah we had
so we had about 300 people at our
wedding which sounds like a ton but then
get this we only spent while we my
parents $10,000 on the wedding we were
in Ohio
nothing it was in Ohio we had a juicer
for dinner it was first of all was
buffet so like they didn't even the
waiters didn't even come around get set
yourself I don't like any of you that
much I was like look we can have a
hundred people and we can have them
waited on or we can have 300 and we can
have a huge buffet I was all about
having more people so we get more gifts
that was my whole thing I was like I
want all the games yes and all the money
and thank you how much did you make from
your wedding oh man
probably right around 10 grand
so you basically could have just gone
out and bought yourself a bunch of [ __ ]
and saved yourself the party if I had it
to do over again because my parents said
to me I remember my mom say give me a
really big gift card to Bed Bath &
Beyond yeah my mom was like you can
either have the $10,000 or you can have
a wedding for up to 10,000 10,000 was
like our max budget for this thing and I
was like of course I want a wedding like
now in hindsight I'm like that was like
that would have been almost a year of
college for me my college is like 15
grand a years and I'd be like four
phases of Juvederm I'm saying that's
like a boob in ass
set to did exactly I mean yeah I buy
mine at Walmart the dollar store yeah I
started really good for dollar store
boobs I'm good could you imagine I saw
an article the other day that I think I
tweeted and it was in like vogue or
something oops are out yeah they said
boobs are out of style and I was like
good maybe I'll go on sale to the Tommy
Hilfiger jeans yeah
now it's Sam's Club guys at Sam's Club
Costco Costco boobies oh my god I had a
my first set were Costco boobies I'm
like aw that's so fiercely bolted on my
first set I don't think guys even
realize how many sets of boobs girls
have to go I might get mine taken out
the next time really yeah I'm thinking
about it I'm just tired of you know I'm
tired of I don't know if you guys know
how much work fake boobs are but if
they're a lot of work you got a massage
you got a massage them all the time you
gotta sleep okay this is so not hot when
I sleep with guys I pretend I'm like I
sleep naked all the time I always sleep
naked like this
no no no when you have fake boobs you
have to like sleep with a sports bra on
or my doctor told me like wrap a belt
around the top you only sleep like like
this is the visual medium so you're like
this yeah you have a belt wrapped around
the top of your tits pushing down on you
remember whether or not I was wearing a
sports before it's a demonstration I'm
so much trouble am I gonna get in right
now I'm impressed that you can pull your
shirt up sitting down and not have roles
like that's one of my life goals I was
sucking in it really hard that's what
you're poor you can't afford foods it's
great right now he can't afford [ __ ]
today I dyed my hair myself in the
shower no you did no as I did I used a
dye I used one of those over the counter
at my hairdresser is gonna kill me but
it's really good guys yeah thank you I'm
so broke right now I was like it's
either go on bray which by the way never
no bad hombre dude bombay is just a name
for girls who can't afford to get their
roots done some poor girl was like i'm
gonna make this a style and i'm gonna
call it arm brain i'm gonna get all my
friends doing it so it becomes a thing
and now it's like if you can't afford to
get your roots done
she kind of is I'd like to have her on
you know what though it was really
prominent in the Jewish community hombre
yeah really it's a lot of sense me
Jennifer I'm like all my Jewish
girlfriends they were like this is the
style now and I was like your boyfriend
was like I'm not paying to get your
roots done [ __ ] deal with it and that's
what happened can we also discuss the
fact that you are wearing part of your
Halloween costume right now Jen do you
gave me this and I'm obsessed with it
yes I'm wearing this necklace which I
wore to be actually for necklaces put
together I know and I think this one's
really like a bike chain I'm never sure
I don't know I'm having a day I'm having
a moment first of all thank you and
you're wearing the Big Daddy Collection
spring collection Costco I'm wearing
these bracelets are from the children's
section at Walmart I have on Jelly Belly
cost three dollars I've got a cross
necklace that looks like it got that
stole again so it's attached to another
necklace like Jerry wicked together it's
like it's stolen from the set of sons of
anarchy I know I know
well it's very Madonna like a prayer
thank you yeah I know I even have like
ripped up tight so I got a pair please
sender's money honey can we talk about
money for a few more minutes because oh
but just real quick before I get on to
money I am planning to sell my wedding
dress
on Twitter and that's gonna be my thing
that I'm gonna do to kind of it's kind
of like people who throw things I tried
on before you sell it no you know why
because I paid to have it professionally
cleaned and boxed and preserved so it's
very like ready to ship out to someone
and it's not here it's in my mom's attic
in Ohio this was my mom's idea selling
the wedding dress my mom said I I said
how much does your mom in her braid and
think that she can get for this wedding
dress mom that dress is so dated like no
one's gonna buy it my mom goes all
fashion comes back around
and here's the thing I got all my
picture day outfits this goes back to
looking at pictures of yourself not
everything comes back around picture day
outfit I just love that you remember
that like the the stuff we were wearing
like when clueless came out that shit's
not coming back are you talking about I
would still wear everything share wears
in clueless you would wear knee-high
socks yeah I do any high socks not
ironically okay no I totally would wear
the schoolgirl plaid skirt with
knee-high socks I dare you to wear
that's here next meeting and see how
that goes I will with glasses challenge
accept the challenge accepted I might
not know one buy yeah I could someone
send me a schoolgirls for me my socks
please how about this let's talk about
let's talk about this money situation
for a few minutes because you know
people think that when you work in
Hollywood you make a lot of money it's a
very common misconception and we don't
as it turns out in fact I know a lot of
people that have had Network sitcoms
that are you know still pretty broke
here's the thing though I think a lot of
it has to do with the fact that we live
in the second most expensive city to
live in do we yeah
home you know in the u.s. anyway I think
it's probably New York Chicago is
probably up there somewhere and Miami's
up there somewhere and LA I feel like
those San Fran is bad here the
difference is in San Francisco and New
York and these other expensive cities
most people have real jobs yeah and like
want to be something besides like an out
here you're trying to convince people to
pay you for your ideas and submits them
that you're talented at something right
right and so you end up you know being
in a situation like I am where your show
is on hiatus and you're doing just stand
up which doesn't pay that much if you're
not hugely famous you're like rocky rich
when you have a TV show though they're
like here's a lump of money yeah be
smart you have to be smart with them
that's like I have a friend who sold a
TV show recently and I ran into him the
other day and I'm like what do you been
doing
with your with your time and he's like
well now that I got money I just sit
around and smoke cigars I don't really
do anything anymore and I was like you
do realize that you sold one show and
that that money won't last forever like
you might want to start cooking up the
next show right now cuz I mean like
money money doesn't last I spread my
[ __ ] out that's why I'm dyeing my hair
with dollar store hair but what I was
gonna say is so I recently had to move a
man into my kitchen no right not at all
no no my good friend Eric Meyers who's a
comedian who needed a place to live and
I was like well I haven't eat in kitchen
with a dining room and all it's in it
right now is a kiddie pool and a free
access to the pool for your $600
contribution to my rent we don't have a
gym but you can walk down the street to
the YMCA so can we just throw away the
pool and I was like so uh so I moved and
set it up and you're just to piss off
when you're ready to move out just set
it up in your parking space and park on
the street and just be like I thought
the whole community could use this how
good would it be if I had an actual pool
party and I invited everyone I know and
then they'd show up and it's a kiddie
pool in my parking space in my drive
most people would anticipate a pool
party being in your house but so anyway
I move Eric in and he's living in the
kitchen and now I have a problem because
I've never had a roommate as a grownup
before it's not fun well how do you have
sex
I can barely masturbate now like he
hears everyone's because your your your
toy sounds like a car it's one
horsepower gets the job done if you
don't have a magic wand
I can't believe Hitachi hasn't sponsored
my
life yet I talk about the magic wand
have you hit them up missed
opportunities you haven't well I kind of
yeah you're right but I probably I think
I will I'm gonna start wearing Hitachi
Magic Wand shirts for no reason I'm just
gonna become the Hitachi Magic Wand girl
until they discover me until they have
to yeah but I don't know have you ever
had a roommate when you were like single
and trying to hook up yeah yeah
absolutely
what did you guys do how did you make it
how did you make it work I just didn't
care really I mean I feel like if you're
allowed enough it gets awkward enough
for them where they leave it's one thing
if it's a girl like if it was you I
would do that I feel weird for my guy
friend to hear me [ __ ] it's weird I'm
loud too I make a lot of noise I'm the
girl that like neighbors like bang on
the ceiling and they're like shut up
like I but that's like in your everyday
life catering I mean it sounds the same
honestly it sound like I'm being
murdered but I like that you know you
know I like to be almost murdered and
bad let's be honest how many times I
come over to see you and you're like why
do you have bruises on your face yeah
and I'm like oh I had the boss so other
people would be like I was assaulted
last night tastes like Jen it was
amazing
it's a form of assault but it's the kind
you advise there's just so many levels
of conversation that's wrong right now
anyway so I recently had a shades of
gray on your face that's Kate actually I
will say this if you're into rough sex
you know cuz a lot of girls are and guys
that I think you should avoid bruising
the face cuz I had a guy bruise my face
and that's not really cool cuz the
problem is then everyone looks at you
like you're the girl in the you know
abusive relationship and that just gets
embarrassing I mean it's nice when they
give you free stuff like it you know at
my coffee be with people they feel bad
for
charge me for a couple of days of coffee
but otherwise it's embarrassing people
think so just don't bruise the face
don't come in the I don't bruise the
face there's the two rules of two rules
of dating by Kate quickly there's really
not much else everything else is fair
game
no it's not but anyway so so I recently
had the point is of the roommate story
is I recently had a night out with a guy
who isn't guy I'm dating but a guy that
I'm friends with that we hook up every
once in a while okay and so we got
together to hang out and then you know
he wanted to hook up that night and I
kind of did too I was in the mood and so
I was like where should we go because I
have a roommate now and I can't [ __ ] you
in my apartment I don't want my roommate
to here and so we had to get a hotel
room to have sex cuz he left you know in
the valley I mean we want to go all the
way away and deep in the valley like
Woodland Hills yeah and so we got a
motel 6 to hook up but it would actually
was so fun
hooking up with the motel 6 cuz there's
no cleanup if you wreck everything like
we'll charge you for damages wait this
whole room cost $100 maybe charge it so
but now I kind of been like oh this is
kind of awesome like I think I'm just
gonna always tell guys we can't hook up
at my place cuz blah blah blah whatever
reason make them get a hotel ok
isn't that the best way to hook up yeah
well I mean it's better than like going
over to their house and like delivering
it you know what I mean yes I know you
don't like when I deliver I like to go
to the guys place usually because I just
I don't like to ice control over when
she leaves yeah that's it I'm like a
dude I want to be able to turn up and
get out get out I only stay and cuddle
let's be real I only cuddle with guys
that look like serial killers
the conversation that we should have
saved for your therapist right I just
there's something about guys that look
like killers that make you in a cuddle I
we're from Ohio that does make a lot of
sense
hi what's wrong with Ohio
thanks for the election guys the
election Ohio and Pennsylvania for being
a [ __ ] if she would have just been cool
and nice and acted like everyone's
grandma baked cookies for people people
that's our bake sales I just feel like
yeah I feel like Hillary tried so hard
to be like a dude
yeah I'm off like a man and be like I
can run this [ __ ] like a man and then
people were like oh she doesn't seem
that's my problem like in real life no
it's not yes you do not come off like a
man guys have a problem with strong
women but we'll get to that but true so
you were into a lot of this stuff was
that you're talking about was coming up
to money stuff and like the whole
concept of whether you and I have very
different opinions on this whether or
not a guy should pay for stuff yeah you
are on a date with them let's talk
really just let men off the hook way too
easy
well that's true I when it comes to
paying for stuff you know what let's
talk about this I think this is a good
this might not even be funny but it's an
interesting topic of conversation we'll
make it funny
because yes people find out what people
find out how much you're worth you'll be
like really because you have this whole
theory I do mean how much I'm worth
financially I don't know I mean like so
we have the theory you and I have talked
about the vagina yeah we talked about
China is worth right however much you
can get a guy to spend on it before you
hook up with him but see I just here's
the thing is okay okay how much is your
vagina worth well we had some
circumstances has been money- dollars
but in other circumstances
name four okay porn guy we'll just call
him porn guy that's what we've called
him forever
let's take porn guy for instance who
turned out to be a douche bag but
shocker shocked but turned out to be a
douche bag for about nine and a half
months yeah it was great okay so like
him for instance he spent a lot of money
before we first hooked up because I hunt
he took me out one night he probably
spent about 150 bucks or so maybe give
or take and then one night he came out
with me and a bunch of my friends and he
paid for everyone's drinks that had to
be at least another hundred why was I
not invited that night I was in Vegas
your honor and then and they took me out
to dinner in in Vegas again before we
hooked so I mean like spent at least
three or four hundred bucks for which is
still low which is still low but I mean
I'm I here's the thing I believe guys
should definitely pay for the first date
a hundred percent and yeah I really I
mean it just depends how you're gonna
define it I think however that money
situation happens you're defining how
the relationship is going forward I
think that I think that it is true that
if a guy has money and he doesn't want
to spend it on you that says somebody's
spending it on like frivolous [ __ ]
sniggers then yeah speakers yeah $25,000
cars that they put $25,000 worth of
improvements into yes but Jenna's right
just to store their cars under let's
talk about Halloween guy I recently had
this is this is where the money things
coming in because I don't want to be
perceived as being a gold digger that's
something I'm really hyper aware of
because in this town there are so
there's so much of it yeah yeah and
there's so many guys and I tend to date
other than not porn guy but like I tend
to kind of try to date guys that have a
lot of [ __ ] going on it might you know
just cuz they have a lot of money I
don't ever want them to think that's
what I'm after so I'm so careful about
letting them spend a lot of money on me
but then sometimes it backfires so like
backfire yeah like recently around
Halloween there's a guy who I've known
for a while a superhot guy who I kind of
started like talking to and hanging out
with we've known each other for a while
but we never really hung out yeah so he
starts inviting me to hang out a lot now
we're friends so there's always like a
weird thing when you're already kind of
friends but you can tell they're sort of
trying to get it in but you don't know
if it's dating or what it is so I go out
with this guy for a few nights of like
drinks in groups with friends and he
never pays for me
he doesn't pay for any of my drinks like
out is it because other people are
around or is it so that's the thing is
that I don't think it's because other
people around soon first of all this guy
had lots of money and it would be really
easy for him to go like one night I met
up with them at a bar there was no
server we were ordering from the bar I
was like I'm gonna go grab a drink it
would have been super easy but he was
like no I got it it's cool exactly what
do you want I'll get it for you like
that but he never did that so then I'm
like okay so he just wants to be friends
in my mind that means you want to be
from yeah he just defined the
relationship period right but then on
Halloween were hanging out at a party
and at the end of the night he makes out
with me so now I'm like oh he's trying
to like you know hook up or whatever
mm-hmm which still doesn't mean he wants
to date me right yeah just be he wants
to hook up so then that was Halloween
weekend not actually Halloween so then I
think like the next night still
Halloween weekend he texts me like hey
me and a bunch of my buddies are going
to this haunted thing this haunted house
thing you should come with us and I was
like oh I love to that sounds really fun
and he was like cool it's $100 dollars
yeah and then I was like oh uh oh so
then I'm texting Jen like what should i
what should I say because I kind of want
to go but if I go we might make out
again and then if I pay for myself I'm
not really sure like what that means so
Jen and I like come up with this text to
send back which is basically like hey
I'd really love to go but I'm really not
in my budget right I'm trying not to
spend money on
things like that right now yeah so I
tried to make it sound like I'm broke as
[ __ ] but also that I didn't want to
spend the money and see what he would
say and he wrote back like damn you're
missing out I'll do I'll drunk text you
after hot even like please don't
well I just didn't say anything to find
the relationship right there that's it
yeah so the definition of that then
according to you is he's just trying to
hook get it in no right no no high up no
but then the thing is that's so crazy is
then like the next time I saw him cuz I
this was during World Series time so we
kept kind of hanging out to watch the
games together
that's kind of like how we kept hanging
out but in groups but then every time
we'd end up like hanging out after and
like talking forever and he's texting me
a lot and that's where I get like
confused
because I guess guys are just trying to
[ __ ] but when you get along with someone
that well and you have like kind of a
connection beyond just physical it
boggles my mind how a guy would not like
wanna take that any further or explore
that like I it's I just don't get it
maybe I'm just sheltered or naive cuz
from Ohio yeah cuz if I meet a guy and
we connect and we're physically
attracted to me I'm like this is so rare
it only happens to me maybe like one guy
out of 15 yeah but I mean that's that's
pretty standard though but I I think it
all comes down to like when you go on
dates with other dudes when you go on
dates with other dudes that you may not
necessarily have that initial like spark
with but they're like being chivalrous
and they're like paying for stuff and
they're opening doors just part of you
like does your brain let go you like
what's he doing I know it doesn't go ooh
I just I mean I do like that like when
why are we so afraid to ask for it
honestly like that's what it comes down
to for me anyway I'm like I shouldn't be
afraid to ask a dude to face none I mean
like to take care of me like if you want
to be with me
you want my company yeah you want you
know to to build this relationship like
girls we invest our emotions like yeah a
lot emotionally yeah guys it's like they
kind of hold some of that stuff back or
at least in my experience they do so
it's like what are you investing in this
relationship that you might you know
that might be worth something to you I
think you're right because I am afraid
to ask for it and I also think wow this
is like personal intervention time guys
but like I also think part of me is that
I would try really hard to be such a
like badass chick who's like strong and
independent and I wanna like set an
example for other girls that you can but
not like a reason to not demand respect
from a dude well there's the whole like
date like a dude thing you can date like
a guy and still demand to be treated a
certain way no totally and that that's
what I was gonna say is that like even
though I put out this image of that and
I do
I mean I'm genuine about it like I
really do think like hey if you want to
take hot photos and wear a bikini at the
DMV but also be a Christian who goes to
church on Sundays and doesn't have sex
with and you I think you should be able
to do whatever you want to do and I try
to really purvey that image but I think
that a lot of guys they see that and
they see me as like this strong
independent chick that doesn't really
need a guy so they're just gonna try to
like get it in but the truth is the
truth is I am like healings
I am such a [ __ ] girl when it comes
to guys when it comes to dating like if
you get alone in a room with me this is
not really what you're getting I'm like
super like sweet and probably way too
sensitive and overly affectionate and I
really like to like tell guys how I feel
and like all the [ __ ] that guys hate
exactly so call her I think I think guys
like maybe hope that they're gonna get
out of me like a chick that's
practically a dude is what I think they
think they're getting but there's a way
but there's a balance to that if you're
dating a tomboy guys understand that
even that tomboy wants to be
treated like a woman yeah and on the
inside dooty is dooty you are I'm a bro
you're sensitive to I'm so sensitive Oh
girls want we all want the guy to make
us feel wanted and cared about and
worried about and like that's really
what girls I feel like that's what girls
really want is like we just want to feel
like the guy really wants us and like
this kind of brings me to so Jen wanted
to talk today and I was kind of fighting
it not talking about it but how I
recently kind of took a little backslide
I just love it this is where you drew
the line at things that you weren't
going to share with people I was like oh
now now it's too much to share with
people I know I talk about [ __ ] my
pants and and lower you did I told the
[ __ ] the pants story on here the
other night on my Instagram go I posted
a photo of me at the Laugh Factory and a
guy goes on my Instagram hope you didn't
take too much calming powder
so yeah you didn't listen to that
episode I recently [ __ ] my pants in
public which is fantastic for everyone
and she still made it through 30 minutes
of stand-up 45 minutes actually it was
really great really great for everyone
that's a whole new meaning of [ __ ]
your pants onstage I would say but no so
I recently had a little back he'll slide
into the porn guy who was gone pretty
much gone he was gone he was gone gone
gone he was bloggers rocked so was i we
had each other blocked to be fair and
everyone's mature in this situation yeah
so and here's the thing I didn't want to
talk about it because I find it really
embarrassing number one that I even and
like in my head think it's a possibility
to have a real relationship with a male
porn star it just shows everything
that's crazy about me but also you know
it's embarrassing because I've said over
and over and over how the guy treats are
exhausted I'm done and I
iseman kate once every two weeks I am so
done with this [ __ ] but it's very
months this time since I'd even seen him
I hadn't even seen him since before I
went to Florida yeah it's been so long
and so but you know it's hot it's the
holiday season and it's almost my
birthday and I just kind of was like
feeling like ah kind of miss him and I
just want that cuddle and I haven't
really there hasn't been someone since
him that I really like felt that much
like mmm
wanna cuddle that guy like that feeling
so and I want to say that everybody has
someone like this in their life that's
really hard to shake that drives then
literally insane yeah and that's where
you go and it's so funny because I can
tell when you get there because you know
who gets the brunt of the [ __ ] me I can
tell when Kate picks a fight with me out
of nowhere
I was like Oh someone saw someone saw
that guy this week and just like I did
not she knew I was like I know and so
she felt the need to like yell at
someone and since I do know it him too
before I know but when he stops
responding you're like I just want a
response from someone huh yeah so I back
slid slightly but here's where we have
to talk about which is so funny because
I think and I've said this before I
think this time I really feel I feel
done with it
I feel like was wasted out here the song
here is what the kicker is and by the
way here's the best part of this story
is that he and I didn't even [ __ ] we
just we spent a night together okay so
what happened is we kind of did that
thing that you do exes do where you're
like hey we should just try to be
friends we don't end things like awful
like this yeah let's be friends and then
by the way the best part is I made up a
fake boyfriend
listen I can't see you anymore now
because I'm seeing Johnny
and so he's equally 15 because then he's
like oh we can just be like friends and
stuff yeah so we talked on the total
[ __ ] by the way that he's like oh no
I don't have the power let me invite her
over yeah
so we talked on the phone one night and
it just you know we're a fake boyfriend
was out do you know that she reminds me
of though here's the thing
he reminds me of no she reminds me of a
vampire okay and here's why because like
no in the movie Twilight how like or if
you read the book Twilight which I know
any guys linked in but every like she
describes him as everything about him is
seductive even his voice is ever this
guy has it over on me to where just the
sound of his voice on the phone the
words like everything he knows how to
say it's like seductive it's like his
skin sparkles and [ __ ] and it's like
when I'm around him there's like this
it's like a drug I'm addicted I'm
literally just at you my ID on drugs
because I've seen this guy
there's nothing sparkly about it I mean
he does have fangs be checked by mu when
Kate like starts doing this stuff by the
way I just like to send her the most
embarrassing pictures I can find of this
person on the internet it is so funny
but I had to even ask her to stop some
like when I if I see it makes me want to
have sex with him you look at a dude in
a vest
bangs and be like I don't love him I've
never said I love him in fact if
anything I don't think we even have
anything in common
nothing in common like the more time I
spend with him the more I'm like what a
rejection thing you just don't like
being like I don't think it's the
rejection thing you know what it is for
me it's just the first here and I think
a lot of girls do this I think this is
really common is that the first month or
two he was so perfect he was so sweet he
was such a gentleman he would call me
and text me and like and pay for iris
walk says that's the representative
that's a presentative yeah but he wanted
you to think is yes but I think what
girls do a lot is I think I just always
in my mind I'm like oh he was like that
she knows how to be like that if I just
act just act the right way he'll be like
that again that's what it did oh my god
to demand that they act that way yeah
well it but here's the thing for me and
him I finally just think I realized and
I hate to admit this I think that he
just wanted to have me around because he
thought in some weird way that I could
like add to his life like benefit like
he could benefit from me being part of
his posse cuz I just think he [ __ ] like
girls that can help him with [ __ ] like I
think that he probably like [ __ ] a girl
who can change as oil and like [ __ ] a
girl that can do his taxes and I really
think that so he'll tell him you can't
get funny through sex but here's why I
decided and here's what he said that
made me like oh [ __ ] I think I'm really
done this time is I talked to him the
other night and uh and so when I went to
see him after our phone conversation he
was like hey I I can't [ __ ] you cuz I
have to work in the morning she does
porn you know so but we can just gotta
save my road yeah we can hang out but
when you can just cuddle okay I can't
believe the actual conversation I know
and I was there like it was like okay
yeah we can cuddle and I went there and
we talked and we we had a good time and
we cuddled and we got along great and I
left thinking like cool next time we'll
[ __ ] you know what I mean
so that was like probably like a week
and a half ago right
so since then I'm like trying to get it
in cuz now I want to [ __ ] him cuz I saw
him and had fun and we have great sex
now
so so I'm kind of like texting him like
dirty you know like I really want to
[ __ ] you like when are you free I want
you to come with me just [ __ ] that you
send to someone you're like in the
[ __ ] right and here's where I'm done
he calls me and he tells me that he
thinks it's weird that I'm so into
[ __ ] him and he's like he's like I
don't know I just wish you would act
normal cuz I feel like the only people
that talk to me that way usually are
like fans which Jen had my favorite line
you were like I think it's funny he
thinks he's I wish you would just scream
grab our conversations because I'm
brutal I know but like so he told me
that he thinks it's weird that I'm sort
of [ __ ] him and then I was like what
I was like most guys love this [ __ ] like
usually if you're [ __ ] a guy but he
does it for a living
I know and that's when it hit me that
like to him really sex is just marvelous
he doesn't care and and that is it could
never work I need a guy that wants to
[ __ ] me as a girl there's nothing you
can do to [ __ ] with the girls have more
then not want to [ __ ] her and it's
starting to make me it's starting to
make me feel insecure which is why I
know I have to cut it because then I I
literally he said I just wish you could
be normal and I'm on my way to a thing
so let's talk another time and we hung
up and I literally text Jen and was like
am I crazy yes cuz I think that it's
normal to want to [ __ ] a guy you're
dating right and one of the send him
flirty texts and like [ __ ] like that and
and having normal guys want to feel
wanted but when that is your actual job
I feel like at some level you're just
like it's kind of like the best way I
could explain it is imagine a guy that
was not a comedian running jokes by you
I'm saying yeah not a comedian maybe not
even funny but he thinks he's hilarious
Oh see what I'm saying yeah he's running
jokes by oh yeah that's the equivalent
of it to him I think that he also
probably gets off on the fact that like
I'm not bragging but I get hit up by a
lot of guys that are trying to but that
just raises his stock yeah I think it on
Tim on guy he can turn me down and you
know so the point of this is this but
the deal-breaker for me though wasn't
that he wouldn't [ __ ] wasn't that he
turned out to be a piece of [ __ ] wasn't
that he's not spending money on me
anymore which by the way the last few
days I did pay for but here's the kicker
for me is he said the word to me I wish
you'd be more normal and that and that
is where she drew the line I got this
because that's it because for me how
dare you say Kate is not normal whoa no
no no I'm not normal but I'm so proud of
being not normal I just think anybody
that like [ __ ] being normal no one who
makes it in this business is normal and
who the [ __ ] defines what's normal
not even like you're the one to tell me
what's normal you have sex for a living
but I live in that it's like you know
what by the way there's peanut butter
under your door hey Jon and I if you go
on my periscope you can watch Jenna and
I trying to put peanut butter under this
guy's door handles which is hilarious
but that was it for me because I have
always people people have been listening
this for a while may know that I'm
obsessed with Eminem I look up to Eminem
like he is like my idol when it comes to
being an artist who's like no one thinks
I'm gonna make it I'm a scrawny little
white [ __ ] who's poor who everyone says
can't rap and I'm never gonna be a star
and he's the hugest [ __ ] star because
he was like [ __ ] everyone [ __ ] being
normal
I'm gonna say whatever I want and
whatever I want and I'm [ __ ] Eminem
now and like sell out stadiums and so to
anyone who tells you to act normal I
think you should say [ __ ] yourself and
never talk to them again which is what
I'm doing and I am saying it here and
sing it to you I will never talk to him
accountable guy I will never talk to him
again
talk to her tweet me every single day I
wish so bad I could saving he is so that
you all could get on his ass but I don't
want to even give him and that's the
best part is the night after we cuddled
he's like yo so can I get on that pause
when can I get on your podcast I want to
come to your podcast and I was like do
you guys want to see him on the podcast
that we or should I wear a mask if he
comes on the podcast and just having fun
we are not letting him come on I'm not
giving him any I don't want to give him
any steam watch out we won't give up we
won't say his name I'm just saying if it
makes him feel better to like tell his
side of the story on the podcast it
could be really funny if he comes on
like in a full costume we don't let his
face be say his name we call him a fake
name even faker than his real fake name
you'd think I should offer that to let
means I have to talk to I don't want to
talk to I don't need I don't think I
should either but I do want to talk to
you guys gen-i I feel like I blabbed the
entire time you are here but I just feel
like we need to get it out and I think
that you had way too much caffeine for
this by the way I have had today two
cups of coffee a suit of bed and an
adderall not on purpose
I forgot I took most people make meth in
their bathtubs in her body I'm really
excited because we have another episode
coming up with Brian Redman who is one
of my closest friends and Jen is gonna
stay on for that but for today this has
been fantastic you can find jen at
jennifer serger you got anything coming
up you wanna plug anything i don't know
we don't want I don't when is this gonna
run tomorrow oh then come see me this
Sunday at the Comedy Store I'm doing the
main room to raise money for puppies and
kitties Oh
Williams will be there it's gonna be a
good time oh my god that's epic wait
that's - that's sunday sunday sunday and
I am
with Brad Williams also coincidentally
Friday and Saturday night at the
flappers and Burbank in the main room
it's gonna be super fun there's still
just a few tickets so if you guys want
to come make sure you get on that and
tweet at me @caitstraightup Medici
cookies and Jenn will be there hanging
out I think at least Friday night so so
we'll see you guys soon this has been
Dave fails have a great weekend bye
bye